There's scientific consensus on a lot of things:j
on climate change...
The best scientists in the world are all telling
us that our activities are changing the climate.
...on HPV vaccine...
The majority of cervical cancer cases are
avoidable if we vaccinate against HPV.
...and that deeply burying nuclear waste is
a good long term solution.
So you would think that the public could agree
on these issues.
In many ways, one would hope that that's true,
right?
The information that we learn about science
ends up getting filtered through our prior
beliefs, through our prior values, through
our religious views, our ideologies.
And as a result, the exact same piece of scientific
information means very different things to
different people.
Compliance for mandatory vaccinations is about
90 percent in the U.S.
But the HPV vaccine, that protects against
cancer from a sexually transmitted virus,
is only mandatory in three places.
You can frame HPV in two ways.
You can either see this as a vaccine against
cancer and leave it at that.
Or you can see it as a vaccine that, as some
people saw it as it was rolled out in Texas
and elsewhere, that would lead to promiscuity.
So why do we disagree on scientific consensus?
What's important to keep in mind here: when
we process new information, the way we as
human beings do that, we put them on mental
shelves.
I don't look at every piece of information
as if it's the first thing I've ever seen.
I basically have in my head a number of mental
shelves that allow me to quickly categorize
new information.
So HPV vaccine— the HPV vaccine is a great
example because I can either put that on a
curing-cancer shelf or I can put that on a
sexual-intercourse-among-minors or among-people-who-we-think-shouldn't-have-that-yet
shelf.
Let's see how that works.
We're going to introduce you to two composite
characters.
We're calling them Marcia and Marie and they
are proxies for a whole bunch of studies that
have looked at this issue.
First meet Marcia.
Hi, everyone.
She's a working professional, college-educated,
she has two children, and she's scientifically
literate.
Now meet Marie.
Hi, everyone.
She's a working professional, college-educated,
she has two children and she's also scientifically
literate.
They are alike but so different.
The government should stop telling people
how to live their lives.
The government should put limits on the choices
of individuals so they don't get in the way
of what's good for society.
It's not the government's business to make
laws that keep people from hurting themselves.
The government should do more to advance society's
goals, even if that means limiting the freedom
and choices of individuals.
Their cultural and political outlooks on the
world differ, and researchers have labels
to describe that.
Marcia has a hierarchical and individualist
view of the world.
On climate change:
I really don't think there's a climate problem
and certainly not man-made.
The HPV vaccine:
I mean, I don't know why my daughter has to
be vaccinated against a sexually transmitted
virus when she's only 12.
And she thinks it's safe to bury nuclear waste.
It's going to be buried very deep underground.
I don't see why that's a problem.
Marie's worldview is egalitarian and communitarian.
On climate change:
Of course climate change is happening, and
we humans are making it worse.
On the HPV vaccine:
As soon as I can protect my child from diseases,
the better.
And on burying nuclear waste:
I'm really skeptical about burying it.
There are earthquakes happening in places
we never thought.
Their worldview affects how they assess risk.
So "culture cognition" is a version of what
we've known in psychology for a long time
as "motivated reasoning".
And motivated reasoning says we, as human
beings, don't reason in a perfectly objective
or neutral way.
Scientific information may be fact-based or
neutral, but how we interpret that information
is not.
We assimilate reality into our biased worldview.
We don't adjust our worldview based on the
reality, but we adjust reality based on our
worldview.
In fact, the more scientifically literate,
the more you stick to your beliefs.
We protect our identities.
It is all about identity protection.
If I'm a strong conservative or strong liberal,
I don't want facts to constantly challenge
what I really hold deep down to be true.
In an increasingly politically polarized world,
how do we fix this problem?
There's a consensus in this room that science
is good.
It's not just interesting but on the whole
it's good.
But at the same time we all know that there's
a conversation about science taking part in
our society that also is divisive.
That people get angry about science.
That some of the divides in society that already
exist are enhanced and deepened over questions
related to science.
And what we want to investigate tonight is
why is that?
And what can we do about that?
Let's meet our panelists.
Our first participant is a Professor of Law
and Psychology at Yale Law School who previously
clerked for Supreme Court Justice Thurgood
Marshall.
He is one of the country's leading researchers
on risk perception and is part of the Cultural
Cognition Project where scholars study how
a cultural value shapes public risk perceptions
and related policy beliefs.
A bona fide expert in the science of science
communication, please welcome Dan Kahan.
Our next guest is a Nobel laureate, geneticist,
and cell biologist.
He has been president of the Rockefeller University
here in New York.
He is now president of the Royal Society of
London— sorry, he stopped doing that in
2015, but he was.
And a member of the U.K. Prime Minister's
Scientific Advisory Committee.
At present, he is the director of the Francis
Crick Institute in London.
Please welcome Sir Paul Nurse.
Our next guest is responsible for a federal
agency that has a budget of $7.5 billion dollars
devoted to science.
Before that, she was president of Purdue University.
She's been a group leader at Los Alamos National
Lab, an astrophysicist, she became NASA's
first female chief scientist.
Please welcome the director of the National
Science Foundation, France Córdova.
And our final panelist is a Professor of Physics
and Mathematics at Columbia University.
Known for groundbreaking discoveries in the
area of superstring theory, he is a bestselling
author, has hosted two award-winning series
on NOVA, his TED talk, "Making Sense of String
Theory", has been viewed over 4 million times,
and a co-founder of the World Science Festival
which is now in its tenth year.
Please welcome Brian Greene.
So on this question of polarization of science
I want to go straight to Sir Paul.
You, last year, produced a BBC program called
"Science Under Attack", which I strongly recommend.
Science created our modern world.
So I want to understand why science appears
to be under such attack, and whether we scientists
are partly to blame.
But what are the battlelines of this attack
that you were talking about?
Well, I think we do have an issue that is
of significance and that is when science comes
up against politics, ideology, and religion,
then we can get quite a potent brew.
And in certain issues— and we saw them in
the introduction, climate change would be
one, vaccination, GMOs— these are particularly
toxic in the public mind.
And really what I wanted to communicate with
that program was that we should initially
look at the science first, if we can do that.
Because obviously, psychologically, we're
looking at everything at the same time.
But we should look at the science first rather
than first of all take an ideological or political
position— and again, we saw that with the
two individuals you had up there— and then
cherry pick the science data to fit with your
ideology, your religion, your politics, or
whatever.
That is the wrong way to do things and that
will lead to a very poor use of science.
And I think that's a critical point that we
should try and address, perhaps this evening.
Do you need to be a scientist to know how
to do that?
You need to be a scientist to produce information,
but we need to have a culture that will recognize
that that is the right way to do that.
And of course, what that means is that we
need to have a society which respects the
process of science— that's a little bit
abstract and perhaps difficult to win hearts
and minds on— and we also need to have a
trust in the scientists who are carrying it
out.
So it's a trust in a process.
It's a trust in the scientists.
But we have to recognize scientists are human
beings.
They are not perfect and they will make mistakes.
Everything isn't perfect that they do.
And sometimes there's even fraud, for example.
We also have to understand that not all science
is on a completely secure foundation.
If we look at Newton's laws of physics they've
been around for three centuries, have been
tested repeatedly, we can tell where a planet
will be within centimeters with great accuracy.
If, on the other hand, you ask a scientist
whether the next Ebola epidemic is going to
kill a hundred million people or one million
people, that's a much more difficult question
to answer.
And science is often, I prefer to use the
term "tentative knowledge", knowledge that
is evolving and developing.
Now if we have those two things together,
that is tentative knowledge and the human
frailty that can produce incorrect science,
that leaves gaps spaces which can be exploited
by those with political and ideological and
even religical opinions to cherry pick what
they want.
And we need to understand all of that process
if we're going to get this right.
France Córdova, I want to…You graduated
from Stanford not planning to go into science
at all.
You graduated with a degree in what?
English.
English Literature.
So what happened?
What happened to me is I was inspired by a
public television show to become a scientist.
I was inspired by the moon landing, of course
that was very dramatic and all.
But it was really the public television show
where they featured scientists talking about
these strange new stars they had discovered
called "neutron stars", and it so captivated
me and I thought, 'What would I ultimately
like to do and give myself over to growing
up?'
And I thought, 'That's what I want to be.
I want to be a scientist.'
So I just went in to— I just knocked on
the doors, actually of some of the people
who were featured in that movie at MIT.
So you make this transition from the world
of not being a scientist into the world of
being a scientist.
You were that layperson who became the professional.
That's right.
What was the thing that you needed to absorb
about how science works that you think maybe
isn't so obvious to regular folks?
I always think of science as an exploration,
of just going to the next frontier, the next
step, and that's the unknown.
And that's a constantly evolving process so
I wouldn't expect science to yield- I expect
it to reveal itself little by little as one
explores it just like any new frontier does.
But never would you know everything.
The universe is so vast and there's so many
things that we have no knowledge of.
You're constantly trying to penetrate and
go deeper into that unknown.
That's the part that drives me.
I think it drives the public as well.
I think they have more curiosity than we give
them credit for.
Well, speaking of public, let me take it to
Brian.
You really are— and I mean this in a very
positive way— a popularizer of science with
the television programs that you do.
But that means that you need to find a language
to speak to people who may not understand
the subtleties.
And it's sort of the same question to you,
and again it's bouncing off of what Paul said,
whether people really grasp what the scientific
process is about.
Yeah.
So I'm going to give you two answers: one
from the standpoint of the science itself,
and the other from communicating the ideas.
And I think from the standpoint of the science,
I think there is a general resistance to being
in a place of uncertainty.
And what happens is when there is a glimmer
of uncertainty, it turns into a general impression
that the scientists don't know what they're
talking about, and therefore I don't really
need to pay attention to what's going on right
now because they haven't figured it out and
they don't know what's going on.
I think a good example of that - which takes
us a little bit away from the political sphere,
which I think makes a nice little laboratory
setting— there is an article in Scientific
American in February not to do with climate
change or vaccines, but having to do with
cosmology.
And the article is basically challenging the
prevailing view of cosmology.
And in response to that, a number of scientists
who believe strongly in the prevailing view
wrote a letter to the editor expressing their
view.
So this has now come out as a disagreement.
And what I expected would happen has happened,
because I've spoken to a number of people
during this festival who have come up to me
with the general impression, 'Ah the cosmology
is now falling apart.
Nobody knows anything that's going on when
it comes to cosmology.'
And the fact is, the only reason why we're
having this controversy is because we understand
things so spectacularly well that now we can
ask the kinds of questions that we couldn't
even ask 20 years ago.
And it's in those fine details that certain
issues are starting to bubble up and different
perspectives are coming to the fore.
So it's a beautiful example of the scientific
process.
Where now, through observation and experiment,
we have a deeper handle on what's going on,
allowing us to go further into ideas.
But when you get it out there into the general
public— say through Scientific American—
the impression that it leaves is radically
different from the actual state of the field.
Dan Kahan— first of all, tell us what you
do for a living.
I'm not sure I do anything for a living.
I haven't worked since June 30th, 1993, which
is the last day before my first academic appointment
became operative.
But I guess the work I do is to study science
communication and risk perception, but to
try to understand the psychological dynamics
that account for the kind of political polarization
that was featured in our opening.
And then to try to come up with mechanisms
or strategies that can make that less disruptive
of what would otherwise be the great benefit
we get from all we know.
So what are the ruling theories on, again,
the situation that Paul laid out?
One thing is, I don't think we should understand
this to be a consequence of limitations in
people's ability to understand science and
maybe problems they have with uncertainty.
One of the most striking things about this
research is that the higher people score on
any measure of science comprehension and critical
thinking, the more intensely they're processing
the information in a way that conforms it
to the beliefs that predominate in their group.
Can you repeat that?
So the people who are highest in science literacy,
the people who are highest in critical reasoning—they're
the ones who most aggressively construe information
about these contested issues in a way that
conduces to beliefs that are in line with
the ones in their group.
So these aren't people who are just confused
about science.
I mean it's actually a tragic thing that they're
using their reason in that way to try to understand
the evidence and the facts in ways that confirm
what their group believes.
But the problem isn't any kind of ignorance
about science at all.
When this happens, people who have very acute
reasoning processes - they're applying their
cognitive resources to get the answers that
support their group.
I want to come back to the specifics of your
research.
But does that surprise everybody else?
I do find it slightly surprising, although
it aligns with certain things.
That would make a lot of sense to me when
the scientific issues directly impact on things
that have relevance to our lives.
Because then, as you say, if a certain kind
of scientific insight might lead to a policy
that goes against how you want the world to
be, I can imagine that all sorts of other
issues bubble up and cause you to— as we've
discussed before— cherry pick an order that
it won't yield that kind of an outcome.
But have you done studies where people are
presented with scientific issues that don't
have that?
Well, and we should be realistic about this.
Most issues don't have this problem.
There are many, many more science insights
about risk that don't involve this perverse
effect of people with different values forming
different views at all, much less people who
have different values and the most developed
capacity for science comprehension polarizing
all the more.
These are issues that are pathological, both
in the sense of being bad but also being rare.
And if you don't understand the great class
of issues that don't have this feature, you'll
never actually be able to have good hypotheses
about what causes it.
And maybe just one quick example on this.
This affects science in a really consequential
way and we should be concerned about it.
But these dynamics are not specific to science.
If I took—was it Marie and Marsha?—and
I showed them a video of a protest and I told
them that the political protest was at an
abortion clinic, then they would come out
with very different views about what they
saw happening.
There was somebody blocking somebody, there
was somebody hitting somebody else over the
head with a sign.
If I them it was a military recruitment center
protest, then they would flip around and see
exactly the opposite.
I mean, I don't know about them as individuals,
but groups of people have their values.
So when facts become entangled in these group
identities so that positions are like badges
of identity and vouchers of loyalty to the
group, people disagree on the facts.
But that's not limited to science.
But the implication of what you're saying
is that there is no solution in just giving
people the facts.
That that's not going to work.
Well in just giving people the facts, they're
going to selectively credit and discredit
the information in the patterns that reinforce
their group beliefs.
And the better they are at critical reasoning,
the more successfully they're going to do
that.
That's not the information that they're missing.
Are you personally immune from that?
Yes I am, personally.
I did a bone marrow transplant from Brian—
thank you for that.
No, I don't think I'm immune from it.
And I think too if I put it this way, probably
most people recognize, 'this could be happening
to me on certain issues.'
But you don't know when.
We say that people are cherry picking, but
they're not doing it consciously.
They're doing it unconsciously.
Paul, again to go back to the documentary
that you did— you talked with a couple of
activists in the U.K. who have taken the position
that climate science is not proven, never
established, and in fact is a very dubious
proposition.
And you sat there— and it's clear what you
think the truth is— and you sat there and
you let them tell you that you were wrong.
And one of them certainly was not a scientist
at all.
One of them was a journalist who, when you
asked him what studies he read, said, "I don't
read studies.
I read reviews of studies that other people
do."
And so you had a very, very pleasant exchange
in which you allowed it to get across that
the two of you had equal standing in that
conversation.
Well, do you have equal standing in that conversation?
And did you have to go outside and scream
after you with talked that guy?
Well you know, I was rather wicked in that
conversation because I realized I was dealing
with an individual who did not believe the
climate was changing, certainly didn't believe
human activity had any role in it.
He came at it through his own politics and
ideology, which I'll talk a little bit about
in a moment.
And he had supreme self-confidence.
And he was so used to people shouting at him—
and then he could get into a fight— but,
as you saw, I just listened politely until
he hung himself.
And I think sometimes the consensual position
can be criticized when in fact, it is most
likely to be the correct position.
Yep.
Um.
Should we talk about— should we talk about
Climategate?
Because I don’t accept your analogy, really.
I think it’s uh… [laughs]
What are folks like you scientists supposed
to do in the face of people who are not scientists,
who perhaps do or do not understand the scientific
process?
Who simply tell you that you are wrong and
that there's a controversy?
Two sides of a story.
I do have some thoughts about this.
I think the first position that scientists
should take is actually to listen to what
they have to say and see whether there is
a way that you can reason and discuss it.
You shouldn't automatically assume that it
isn't possible to have dialogue and debate.
In the issue of climate change, you can understand
why there's a range of views.
It's a very complex subject.
It's one that is very data-ridden.
The models are difficult to do.
There are all these holes that people can
occupy because there are gaps in the science.
And what has emerged there in climate change
is something that I think is really quite
interesting.
Because there is some debate about the science.
But what I think influences it most is, what
do you do if there really is climate change
being caused by human intervention?
Because what you do is very significant for
individuals' beliefs.
Because the only way you can deal with it
is something like the Paris Agreement, which
requires agreement across countries, top-down,
and doesn't allow the individual or the company
or even the state or the country to find their
own way.
It requires collective action.
And that collective action is an anathema
to those of a certain political bent and a
certain ideology.
On the other hand, for another section of
society it's actually the way they think and
the way they like to think about issues.
That means that the science problem turns
into a political problem because the minds
are lined up really on politics rather than
the science.
And then you get all the dirtiness of political
discussion being thrown at the science.
And I think that, from my amateurish view
of this, has been the real problem here.
It's become a political issue and the science
is refracted through those politics.
We are talking about polarization, but there's
actually evidence that there's almost a sort
of vast silent majority of citizens who are
behind science.
I mean, there were surveys done where the
question was whether the U.S. federal government
should even fund science.
And as you can see, that orange in the graphic
is overwhelming support for science on the
part of the general public.
And then a second question was asked about
whether there's enough money going to science.
And again surprisingly, the majority of the
public so there's not enough money being spent
on science.
Can I make one point?
We should really be cautious not to characterize
this kind of disagreement as the people who
believe in science and the people who don't.
How should we?
First of all, everybody— as those graphics
were helping us to see— have very positive
views of science.
They're just as confused or just as much in
a state of polarization over what the majority
of scientists say or over scientific consensus,
as they are on the facts of whether global
warming is happening or whether deep geologic
isolation of nuclear waste is a sensible idea.
Those are examples that we used in an experiment
to test whether people could recognize scientific
expertise.
And it turns out that people will recognize
a scientist as an expert if that person has
the same view as their group on an issue like
deep geologic isolation of nuclear waste or
climate change.
So they're engaged in a kind of biased sampling.
But at the end, both sides say that scientific
consensus is on their side.
This is like nations going to war saying,
"God is on our side."
Nobody is out there saying, "Screw the scientists."
Not in the general public, at least.
We have another graph that takes a look—
in fact— at public trust, I believe is the
topic, in scientists and medical scientists,
which may or may not come up—
The GSS, the General Social Survey has been
doing this for 40 years.
Science is always second out of 13 institutions.
Sometimes it's the military, sometimes it's
the medical profession but it's always been
second and it's been second for both Republicans
and Democrats.
Republicans trusted the science community
during the Reagan administration more than
trusted the executive branch.
People who were religious in nature trust
science more than they say they trust organized
clergy.
So we're not in a society where people are
questioning, but they have a hard time figuring
out what scientists believe on some of these
issues.
Brian, you're in primarily physics and the
physical sciences.
Is it a different kind of - do you face these
kinds of controversies in the same sort of
way?
I know you told the story you told before,
but does it get as politicized?
Well no, I feel that we're in a fortunate
position because most of the people are spending
their energy fighting against these folks
in the biology and climate area.
They haven't gotten to physics yet.
Maybe that happens in the future.
And it's largely because what we're doing
doesn't have a direct impact on policy, that
has something where one can tangibly see it'll
affect their lives in one way or another.
And aligned with that, relevant to the question
you asked before, again, in terms of quantum
mechanics and general relativity, say— these
are complex and rich and deep subjects.
But in a way, they're very simple in that
there aren't a lot of moving parts.
It comes to climate change, goodness gracious.
Let me give you an example.
I've been asked to be on programs to talk
about climate change.
I don't do it.
You know why don't do it?
I don't feel like I have a grasp of the science
at a deep enough level where if there's somebody
really good from the other side, that they
won't be able to destroy me.
Whereas I know with almost certainty that
that will not happen if it's a discussion
about quantum mechanics or unified theory
or general relativity.
So I feel completely comfortable discussing
that with anybody regardless of how skeptical
they might be.
But climate is such a complex subject that
even for a scientist, it's difficult.
I actually tried to start to read the literature.
I said, "Let me educate myself once and for
all so I can just handle all of these climate
issues straight out."
And I start to read the papers, and a week
or two in, I'm like, "I can't do this.
This is going to take up my entire life because
it is so complicated."
Now again, that's not to say that I am a skeptic.
It's to say that there's so many moving parts
that to be able to rebut any argument that
comes at you requires a level of understanding
and a depth of understanding that's difficult
to achieve.
Whereas in the physical sciences, go through
graduate school and you're there.
So that's the difference.
Paul, take climate change then.
If it is so complicated that even the brilliant
Brian Greene stopped after a couple of weeks,
what is everybody else supposed to do in figuring
out what their position is?
Well as I was saying about climate change
because I'm with Brian, I mean it's a complex
subject.
There's many holes and it takes a lot of navigation.
I think what we have to do if we can is to
have, if we can, a more mature discussion
about science in society and with our political
leaders.
We have to somehow communicate the strengths
of science, the weaknesses of science, this
tentative knowledge point that I was saying,
that we cannot always say things with certainty.
I think one problem in school is that science
is often taught with complete certainty.
And that is a real difficulty.
Another problem with school is that we don't
focus enough on the process of science and
how you do good science.
And so I think we have to start there in education.
Give us the 45 second process of science—
bottom line— that people can take home.
I think I prefer to answer the question in
terms of, what are the attributes of good
science?
And the attributes of good science are respect
for good data observation and reproducible
results.
We are an empirical activity.
We have to look at the evidence, so we're
relying on good observation.
The second is rational argument - simply applying
the logic, trying to be as objective as you
can having recognized that we are human beings
pushed around by our feelings and by our other
beliefs.
So rational argument is the second.
The third is skepticism, particularly of your
own ideas.
So you attack your own ideas.
And finally you go through a process that,
with those observations, you come up with
a hypothesis, an idea to explain the phenomena
of interest and then you attack it.
You don't actually try to defend it, you attack
it.
And if it survives sufficient attacks, then
you can start thinking this could represent
it.
Do you realize how vital that is?
Scientists are the most skeptical people around,
and yet there is a line that's out there in
the public that somehow they'll defend a perspective
to the death.
No, we try to kill it every step of the way
and only if it survives every sledgehammer
that we throw at it, are we willing to believe
it or have confidence in it.
That's a very different process.
But here's one thing: I think that the analogy,
Brian, between you and the member of the public
breaks down.
They're not going to understand anything on
their own by pouring over it.
And they're going to have to accept much more
is known by science then they could possibly
understand.
They don't become experts in any area of science
inable to do that.
They become experts at figuring out who knows
what about what.
And they're not even hearing from scientists,
they're immersed in social networks.
And those do, generally speaking, a very good
job of leading them to what the truth is.
But when they're in social groups that are
at odds with each other, they're just doing
the same thing that they ordinarily do to
figure out what science knows and really,
there's no alternative to it.
I think that we perhaps don't use enough is
"trust".
When I say we need to have a more mature discussion—
with society and politics— of course they
cannot understand the science, of course they
can't understand what Brian does.
But they can trust Brian, and they can trust
the process.
And I think we need to do the following things:
we need to focus on developing trust in science
and trust in scientists, and I think in practical
terms we need to work with our politicians.
When they disagree, you need to have courteous
debate.
I don't mean lobbying, which actually I think
is perhaps too prevalent, particularly in
the U.S.
Because what do scientists do?
They go and see their politicians when they
want more money.
Otherwise they take no notice of them.
What we need to do is to make friends with
the politicians and get the politicians working
with scientists to provide leadership in these
sorts of issues.
Do you see a change in this trust issue over
the course of your career?
I want to take that to France.
Well there's a lot more social media now.
And as Dan was saying, there's a lot more
places to get one’s information and there's
a lot more so-called "experts" around.
So that's certainly— people can always pull
up or grab on to something to affirm their
beliefs.
But there's a vast number of people in the
middle—the bulk of of humanity— that is
curious.
Even if you have a belief, if you're Marie
or Marcia in the video, if you're a curious
Maria or Marcia, you will be open to having
your thinking changed with the right narratives
and stories about the research that's being
done and so on.
And those are the people that I want to address.
I'd like to give you an example of something
that I did about a week ago.
I accompanied nine congressmen and their staff
to Greenland—to see the Arctic ice sheet
in Greenland.
And I think everybody here can appreciate
that since it's covered by ice, the whole
thing, that we're talking about glaciers receding
and the sea ice melting and environmental
change on a very big scale that is noticeable
over the period of just years and the decade.
And are— I think the approach was very much
just to go and see and show them our facilities
there, the kind of research we're doing, and
also with other agencies.
And when people can see for themselves—
and these were congressmen that cross the
spectrum of belief about certain things, and
from both sides of the aisle.
And I think it was really revealing, without
being at all heavy-handed.
Just going to the different sites and showing
the ice core bore down more than a mile deep
and taking samples of emissions of gases down
150,000 years ago, to the research on the
ice and the glaciers and so forth.
They all asked a lot of very, very good questions.
And I think that's kind of the approach that
I think of scientists just doing more of,
is inviting elected officials to universities
to see their laboratories, meet their students,
see the kind of research they're doing, have
them ask the questions instead of putting
things and ideas in front of them and feeding
them, is let them feed themselves by being
exposed more.
Do you think any minds changed on that trip?
It's an excellent question and I don't know.
Sometimes one prepares one's mind to change.
I'm not sure that we saw somebody jump up
and have an aha moment.
Although people did say, "I need to go back
and read more about this.
I need to learn more."
An interesting distinction between the climate
change discussion here and the discussion
over genetically modified food in the U.K.
is that here, the challenge to the consensus
tends to come from the right.
But Paul, tell us what's happening with the
question of GMO food in the U.K.
Well it's exactly as you said.
In the U.K., climate change and the man-made
cause is more or less accepted.
But there's been much greater resistance with
GM crops compared with the U.S.
And this is really quite interesting and I'm
not sure I can answer it in the general way
that you're asking, I can only describe what
sort of happened.
The first thing that happened is that Monsanto—that's
the company who first marketed engineered
tomatoes—was inept and put these adverts
up about how wonderful this all was.
And the consumer saw nothing for them, they
just saw something for Monsanto.
Secondly the scientists like me were inept,
because when we tried to explain it, we didn't
take the rather obvious route of asking some
of the public what they thought about this
issue.
We simply lectured them about how this was
all wonderful.
In studies that I was involved in a year later,
we did ask that question.
Do you know what the most common reply was?
I was really astonished.
The most common reply was that they didn't
want to eat food with genes in it.
And if it's funny of course, but they didn't
fully appreciate that all food has genes in
it.
That was a good, hearty American laugh.
And we had never asked them that question.
So we weren't even beginning to be on the
same table.
What's the answer there?
You have to talk to the public to find out
what it is you have to deal with.
Can you clarify, what is the scientific consensus
on GM food?
In the U.K.?
In Europe?
Oh, in the world.
The scientific consensus is that GM is a technology
that can produce different outcomes.
And just like conventional breeding.
But what you should be testing is the final
product to see if it's safe and can be eaten
and used safely in the environment.
I mean we are GMOs.
We are GMOs ourselves.
A human being is, right?
I mean how do we get here?
It's just by a slightly different process.
Yes, but we don't eat ourselves.
Or at least most of us don't.
Maybe in New York of course.
But the point is that the GM modifications,
where they're produced by normal breeding,
often involving, by the way, hitting those
plants with heavy mutagenesis.
So you have no idea what you've done with
them.
Versus a GM modification.
So that's the consensus.
But the resistance is, partly we're playing
God— manipulating things—, partly anti-corporate
and big companies—because they're making
it—and once again we're seeing the politics
bleeding into this.
And partly—and this was a tipping point
in the discussion—when the media, the newspapers
in this case, looking for a good headline
so they could sell another 100,000.
We had this headline in The Daily Mail—if
it is a newspaper, that's one of these rags
that we have in the U.K.—calling "Frankenstein
foods".
It killed the debate for 15 years.
It's only now being resurrected and it is
being resurrected now.
I'm on the Scientific Advice Mechanism for
the European Union.
We have just produced a report on GMOs at
the request of the commission, because they
are going to now re-approach this.
But it took 15 more years to go by before
it could be re-addressed.
Brian, what do you hear in that story?
That in the U.K., —something that here we're
incredibly blasé about GM foods— that over
there, that's in a sense their climate change
in the sense that much of the general public
does not trust the scientists.
Yeah.
It's perhaps hard to predict which issues
are going to raise what sort of thought process
that's going to create resistance.
And I guess I don't know.
Dan, is there a cultural difference where
you can put your finger on where that is the
cause of it?
I mean, one thing it makes you conscious of
is that there's a great deal of accident and
fortuity that creates these kinds of associations
between positions on facts that, amid scientific
inquiry, over space and across time, you see
just lots of changes.
Which ought to make us realize too that no
technology is destined to have the kind of
resistance that GM foods have in Europe.
We should get on top of all the influences
that do steer technologies down one track
or another.
Doing survey work in case studies to understand
why that happened there and why it hasn't
happened here ultimately will make us smarter
about how to prevent it from happening as
often as it does.
But do you advocate actually looking at a
particular constituency, taking a given scientific
idea, and packaging in a way that somehow
will avoid some of the pitfalls that you think
are the cause of why—
The HPV vaccine is a great example.
Because at the very time that we were in the
midst of this very contentious political debate
about whether schools should adopt it as a
mandate for—
Stop again and remind us what the HPV vaccine
is.
So the HPV vaccine is a vaccine that protects
women, but also men.
There's no test for determining whether men
have HPV, but they clearly do contract it
and disseminate it.
It is an extremely common sexually transmitted
disease that causes cervical cancer.
It's the only vaccine that was proposed by
the CDC for universal administration that's
not on the list across the states for mandatory
school enrollment.
But at the time that we were having a very
bitter contentious fight about that, we also
had the HBV vaccine for Hepatitis B. Hepatitis
B is also a sexually transmitted disease and
it causes actually more cancers than HPV.
At the time it was being administered to adolescents.
Now it's administered to infants, but there
was a catch up regime.
There was no dispute about that.
You could look at HPV and say, “Well, it
was bound to have conflict because you're
talking about parental autonomy and about
sex.”
Same thing with the HBV vaccine.
The difference was that people learned about
the HBV vaccine from their doctors.
They learned about HPV from watching Fox and
MSNBC go at each other because there was a
legislative proposal to do this.
Usually it's done by non-political health
administrators.
And so we knew that was going to happen, it's
not like the evidence was rejected.
But we don't have any process for assessing
how these kinds of advances in knowledge will
be presented to the general public.
So to Brian's question, you need to know where
are the accident's going to happen?
You should be trying to simulate the conditions
under which people are going learn about these
new technologies from a medical advance like
the HPV vaccine to other kinds of things like
nanotechnology and the NSF— that's clearly
their philosophy.
Let's learn as much as we can about the kinds
of ways of educating people that are likely
to provoke this kind of polarization and the
ones that won't.
John, could I just ask one more question?
I don't mean to take the role, but just one
question that comes to mind here.
So if we were to have a better educational
process early on, that kids really understood
what science is about— I know that they
don't.
There are fantastic teachers around the country,
do not get me wrong, this is not fully general.
But I've spoken to so many kids around the
country whose perspective on what science
is, is memorization, get the facts, know the
equation— that's all that it is.
If the process that Paul was talking about
was somehow ingrained really early on, could
you see that bubbling up in a way that would
mitigate the issues that you see?
Actually what we do see, as I said, is that
when an issue has taken on this kind of status
where the positions are badges of membership,
the people who are the most divided culturally
are the ones who are highest in all of the
kinds of critical reasoning faculties that
you were talking about.
But does that really capture an understanding
of what science is and they know that in their
bones?
Do you test that in a way that really captures
that?
Oh they know what science is.
Oh sure, you have critical reasoning problems
about covariance detection and conditional
probability, all kinds of things that people—
Nah, c'mon.
Yeah, c'mon.
I'll administer the test to you.
I want to bring in the audience for some questions.
But now you see you won’t—is it your cultural
view that's causing you to dismiss this?
Is it the culture of being a scientist?
There’s a science—and we need a science
of science communication if we're going to
address these problems.
And we need to have institutions that will
use it.
We're going to put some microphones up for
you to line up and ask them questions, but
we did ask you the questions when you came
in.
And here are the results.
On the question of whether climate change
is man-made, 93.4% of you said yes.
On the question of whether there is something
wrong with GMO food, 39.1% said yes.
And whether you support the burial of nuclear
waste, 46% said yes.
I’m curious in light of the—
The burying nuclear waste?
There's scientific consensus that that's OK.
The National Academy of Sciences was tearing
its hair out about why the public didn't accept
that long before climate change.
I mean it's kind of revealing that this audience,
only 46% think that that's safe.
But you're telling them that's OK.
So we can poll them again and see how influential
you are.
I'm telling you that the same groups that
don’t believe— that make a mistake about
scientific consensus on climate change make
a mistake on the scientific consensus on deep
geologic isolation of nuclear waste.
If you were to phrase the nuclear burial question
in terms of, "Do you feel really strongly
about your position?"
I really wonder if the data would have been
different.
Can we just quickly do that?
Only answer if you feel really strongly about
the issue.
How many people think that it's OK to deeply
bury nuclear waste?
And how many people think it's not OK?
It's about the same I guess.
Do we have any questions yet?
Because we have some coming in from online,
from YouTube from Laurie Brummett.
She is asking, "What are ways in which these
panelists are working to change the public
perceptions of science?
Or should people with influence and power
be doing something to change the perceptions?"
Why don't we take that to you, Brian.
Uh, we're not doing anything.
No?
Yeah, just the World Science Festival.
No, that's what this festival is!
It's not that every scientist should be out
there talking to the public.
I think there are some whose time is better
spent just in the laboratory doing their work.
But those who are interested in doing it and
those who feel called to do it, I think many
are going out and speaking to the public.
Look, when we started this festival there
was definitely—that was 10 years ago—there
was definitely some uncertainty on the part
of some scientists about, “Do I want to
be part of this?
Do I want to be out there in the public?”
Now we have scientists all year round lobbying
to be part of the festival.
So there's a change in perspective that getting
out there and talking to the public is important
and really matters.
And I think culturally, we even see it right
now.
I mean again, let me just be personal about
it.
A couple of years ago, I would not be on this
panel.
The only thing I'd ever talk about is the
subject that I work on as a scientist.
And now I feel moved to be a little bit more
broad because we see what's happening in the
world and we have to step up and do something
about it.
We even see scientists— now there's a new
group of scientists who are pledging to run
for public office.
It used to be “No, no, we stay away from
that.”
But now we're going forward.
France, I see a lot of nodding from you on
that part.
I see a lot of nodding from you on Brian's
point.
I mean we are embracing uncertainty a lot
more and being in uncomfortable and challenging
situations.
My agency spends over $60 million a year funding
what we call "advancing informal science learning".
And that's money that goes to public broadcasting
stations, it goes to museums, it goes to science
festivals.
And that's all to try to do better about the
public communication of science.
And these events are widely, widely attended.
I mean some of our museums in this country
have millions of visitors a year that want
to do hands-on science.
Let's go to a question.
Ma'am?
Hi there.
We have a problem with the global warming
and oil producers and people like that that
are making that a big problem.
But we also have nuclear weapons and that's
the other big thing that can annihilate the
planet and civilization, and we wouldn't have
them if it weren't for scientists.
The question is what are scientists doing
about it?
How are the able—we don't have Linus Pauling
anymore, or Joseph Rotblat.
Who are the scientists that will speak up
or say something about their colleagues who
are making these things?
I think that's a really important thing if
you want trust.
That's a good question.
Let's take it first to Paul.
You're on the spot.
Well I was a member of CND, who actually—
Campaign for Nuclear Disarmament.
Scientists do speak out against the use of
nuclear arms.
It is, of course, a personal opinion.
So it's not actually to do with science, it’s
to do with the use of them and it's just like
any other member of the public.
Some will speak against them and some not.
If the question was—which it sort of got
close to saying— without scientific understanding,
we wouldn't have nuclear weapons.
And so, is that an attack on scientific understanding?
Well I would say, without science we wouldn't
have many, many other things and I think that
isn't the right way to think about it.
So you're including nuclear power?
Science gives you the knowledge, it's the
use of the knowledge... you wouldn't have
nuclear power— well some don't like that
either.
But science produces the knowledge, society
has to determine how the knowledge is used.
Thank you for that question, very provocative.
A question from over here.
Hi.
You guys earlier talked a little bit about
uncertainties that are inherent to— and
perhaps well understood by—scientific consensus,
things like uncertainties and confidence intervals.
But there have been plenty of cases in the
past where science has been just flat out
wrong, whether that's because there is some
element we didn't understand or perhaps there's
some methodology that we're picking up some
sort of noise.
So to play devil's advocate a little bit,
I was wondering what you guys think the probability
is that we're wrong about something like climate
change and whether or not we should accept
some amount of humility about that.
Well I emphasise that we should look upon
science as a spectrum.
There is tentative knowledge and there's firmer
knowledge.
And I think that's really where it is.
And there’s different areas that you can
put different probabilities to.
And our responsibility is really to communicate
that uncertainty and that probability.
I think we should be wary of thinking when
a piece of research or an idea turns out to
be wrong, as if that is just entirely negative.
Because it isn't, as we touched on before.
Science moves by this process of being wrong
about things, which then cleans out certain
ideas.
So I do think that we have to be a little
more open about the fact that there will be
mistakes made in science and that's part of
the process.
And I'm not talking about fraud or anything
like that.
It's just that we make observations, they
may not be accurate in certain ways.
We may have an idea and they don't take everything
on.
But that is just the process of science.
Sir, before you leave the mic, I'm curious
to know whether you found that answer satisfying.
I think so.
I mean I was thinking more of results such
as the recent BICEP results, which we all
know were about primordial gravitational waves,
but they're very certain—
Let's take that as an example because it's
much easier to speak of since it takes it
out of the political realm.
So here is a result that was announced.
Incredibly exciting that we might have detected
gravitational waves.
Brian, can you catch everybody up?
So a few years ago, before the recent discovery
that was announced February 11th of 2016 that
we had finally discovered gravitational waves,
there was a previous announcement by a team
at the South Pole that they thought they found
indirect evidence for the existence of gravitational
waves.
It got the world of science incredibly excited
and the data looked kind of strong.
But over the course of just a few days to
weeks, scientists converged on this and began
to raise issues.
At Columbia, within a few days, we had a group
meeting where experts say, "Well, we don't
know, it may be dust in the foreground.
They didn't talk about foregrounds in the
paper."
And so the community came together and within
a year, it was determined that the interpretation
of the data was incorrect, that it wasn't
gravitational waves.
That's beautiful!
That's not something bad.
That's the ability of science to self-correct.
That's the beauty of it all.
And just to emphasize that, when that result
came out I made a big poster picture—and
dry mounted it—of the B-polarization background
map, the famous one that then turned out to
be incorrect or was actually mapping dust
in our own galaxy.
And I take that out and show it to visitors
every once in a while.
That is one of my favorite, favorite stories
of the progress of science.
Now the people that wrote the paper may feel
exactly that way, but we're talking collectively,
the community we're talking about here.
Over here.
So recently, there was a book and also several
articles which dealt with the reproducibility
crisis in biomedical research and I'm wondering
whether you, the panel, think that that is
something which is going to hurt science in
the public perception generally?
And what we should do about that?
I think I've got to catch that one, haven't
I?
Yes, reproducibility, particularly in medical
science actually.
I got a few comments to make.
The first thing is that biological research
is made with biological material.
Biological material is often very variable
and some of this reproducibility issue is
around the fact that you're not always working
with exactly the same things because of their
biological variability.
A second aspect to this is that some of the
the techniques being used are very sophisticated
and complicated, and can be difficult to actually
reproduce.
There is something that's growing up, that
if somebody says ‘this’ and then somebody
doesn't get the same result, this person is
always wrong.
That isn't actually necessarily the case.
This person might be wrong.
It is part of actually the process.
Then there's a third aspect of it, which is
the one that is spoken about most, which is
that people are just making it up and it's
fake science and they're trying to make money
and they're driving things through.
And there is no question in my mind that there
is some pressures in this direction: pressures
for people's careers, to get interesting results,
to get interesting papers, sometimes just
commercial interests.
And my view about that is that we simply have
to have a good culture in scientific research
where that is simply not acceptable.
It's acceptable to make genuine mistakes because
that will happen sometimes.
It is not acceptable to be sloppy in the work.
It's not acceptable to be fraudulent.
I sum it up: science is a high calling, and
I'm not sure we emphasize enough, it is a
high calling and we have to hold ourselves
to high standards.
Thank you very much everybody.
Goodnight!